over 45 minutes thanks for that
introduction and thanks for coming out
tonight
what Jerry and I have in mind is that
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
book including reading a short excerpt
from it and then Jerry's going to talk a
little bit about our our long history
with this story and where I want to
start is to remind everyone about the
significance of this story
I mean Whitey Bulger it's a big one a
big topic but the distinguishing thing
about whitey and I think what makes him
at this point
historic crime figure in terms of crime
figures and where they rank in 20th
century America I mean he's got the body
count to match other crime bosses he's
been charged with 19 murders and there's
probably many more
he's got the longevity he's been around
a long time and he certainly has made
millions but the distinguishing feature
I think and we have found with Whitey
Bulger the thing that sets him apart
from any other crime boss that might you
become a household name whether it's
Dillinger Al Capone or some of the Mafia
dons or whoever they might be
is that Whitey Bulger brought the FBI
the nation's top law enforcement to its
knees he harnessed the power of the FBI
on his behalf
and that's what gave him his rise to
power and his longevity and no one else
in this in this you know underworld can
has that claim to fame so to speak
that's his is I think you know his
historic marker that we all should never
forget because he compromised the FBI
for so many years it's a subject it's a
topic which we went deep on in black
mass in fact the 20 years in which you
know why he had his his so-called unholy
alliance with the FBI
we now refer to as the Black Mass years
but we and we have taken those years and
and and in the new book whitey we have
put them in the large
context the full arc of his long life
and getting into the project we actually
as the research you know for the past
year or so you know got underway we were
astonished by how much new material new
information we were able to uncover and
work with in trying to put together the
long life of Whitey Bulger taking a look
at the making of the monster the how and
why of whitey these are all things that
if when you read whitey you're going to
be reading about whether it's tracing
the family the history of the family
back to Ireland for the first time it's
never been done before whether it's
having the benefit of his his prison
file when he was away for nine years in
various federal prisons including
Alcatraz 600 pages of previously
unexamined material when you read whitey
you're going to be reading letters that
bill brought Bulger wrote to to prison
officials about his brother and trying
to improve his brothers lot
you're gonna read letters from Whitey
Bulger to some incredibly famous people
like father Robert drying it again
something we'd never knew before you're
gonna read you're going to find out
about prison reports that that tracked
his evolution through the prison system
that began in Atlanta and ended at in
Lewisburg in Pennsylvania it's really
remarkable stuff and and one of the
things that you know I mean we've been
with this store and close to it for a
long time but it was eye-opening was
that when you're looking at whitey
Bulger's long life
doors open to all kinds of other worlds
it might be the to know the 30s and 40s
in Boston and the study of juvenile
delinquency it could be the you know the
science and the study of the criminal
mind and Psychopaths
we went there it could be about the FBI
and its history through the 20th century
as it waged a national campaign against
organized crime and created this top
echelon informant program which whitey
was so cleverly manipulated in his
behalf it can be about Alcatraz you know
the most famous prison fascinating stuff
that I don't know if anyone's familiar
with with the the famous Alcatraz inmate
named Frank Lee Morris
the escaped from Alcatraz Fame and
putting all this stuff together all
these various resources and realizing
that while Whitey's in Alcatraz and he
knew Frank Lee Morris because they both
been in Atlanta previously that well
frankly Morrison and two or three other
inmates were using spoons to dig these
secret tunnels
why do you the smartest one of them all
probably was using and working with his
brother and House Speaker John McCormack
one of the most powerful men in the
country to go out the front door well
the other guys are going out the tunnel
never to be seen again so that's the
kind of thing that you can end up
putting together when you have these you
know new vast resources that we had
another door that opens up is the is the
CIA backed secretly back LSD project
that was underway through the late 50s
and into the early 60s and wide he
played a role in that and that's the
excerpt of the brief passage I want to
read from because when whitey went away
as a 26 year old to start serving a
sentence for bank robbery in 1956 his
first stop was Atlanta and within a few
months his first sell he had to share a
cell with seven under other inmates and
one thing about Whitey Bulger that we
realized is that he's a control freak
and even at 26 he pretty much freaked
out when he had seven other inmates
veteran criminals that he had to share a
small space with and they were driving
him nuts and within three months of his
incarceration he checked himself into
the psych ward at Atlanta and within a
year or so he became involved because
that's where it was going on this so
called LSD project and that's what I
want to read a brief briefly to you
about in July of 57 have about a year in
at Atlanta he had gotten a job in the
prison hospital that's where his work
assignment that's where his work was had
become it was the new job that gave
whitey an up-close look at the LSD
project now nearly 2 years old held on
Tuesdays and Thursdays in the basement
of the prison hospital word about the
project had already
publicly beyond the walls of the prison
the Atlanta journal-constitution had run
a feature story about the experiments
under the headline drug fed prisoners
eight study along with a photograph
showing one of the doctors interviewing
an inmate volunteer the article began 16
prisoners at the Atlanta penitentiary
are helping medical researchers study
mental diseases by voluntarily taking a
potent drug that induces signals of
schizophrenia that was the idea of the
LSD project I don't know you know it's
hard to go back in time and it certainly
was before my time but there was a
public face to this LSD project it was
going on in the prison was going on at
Harvard and a couple of other facilities
doctors were trying to come up with a
cure for schizophrenia and and this new
drug called LSD seemed to make someone
what they called instantly insane so
they would have volunteers take LSD be
tripping their brains out and then they
would try and test Berry's drugs on them
to see if if it was could be a cure or a
remedy for the schizophrenia the induced
you know that LSD did I mean that was
the idea behind it and it wasn't secret
at all it was a very public thing it was
written about in in whitey bulger was
one of a number of inmates who
volunteered for it the thing that came
out much later that way and that we've
always had heard a little bit about
perhaps is that the CIA had a secret
role in it where they were feeding these
doctors in Atlanta at Emory who were
involved in this you know other drugs to
test on the subjects in addition to the
LSD as part of their kind of espionage
and counter espionage chemical warfare
interests so that was the secret private
side that didn't come out four years
later but it was a very public project
at the time so there was a big store in
the Atlanta paper about it the newspaper
interviewed the lead doctor Carl C
Pfeiffer of Emory University in quoted
from a colorful account of one inmates
LSD trip the newspaper did not identify
the inmate but why'd any other prisoners
easily could have recognized him as
Winfield Burdette
the newspaper without credit had lifted
the description of the trip that
Burdette had written for the Atlantean
which was the prison magazine was they
covered it in their own prison magazine
the inmate publication in other press
coverage about this LSD project a
national magazine called man's magazine
in an issue that included such articles
as Ted Williams hit heel or hero in
virgins would you marry one ran on a
cover story titled I went insane for
science and the author was a doctor
writing anonymously about his
experimental LSD trip and the article
included mention of Pfeiffer's work in
the Atlanta prison wide he met with
Pfeiffer and Pfeiffer's associates just
a few weeks after he started working in
the hospital in July he underwent a
screening process overseen by Laurence L
Brian the prison psychologist who had
admitted whitey to the psych ward the
previous October inmates called him the
nut dr. dr. Brian interviewed whitey and
administered psychometric tests which
included a Rorschach test designed to
confirm a volunteer was normal doctors
involved in the LSD project when writing
or talking about the inmates meant
normal in quotation marks because none
of them was that the lead doctor was
quoted saying inmate volunteers had all
scored high in test for psychopathic
tendencies they were not normal he said
they were Psychopaths the point of the
psychological screening then was to
ensure the inmate was stable and could
withstand the projects regimen of LSD
and other drugs quote except for
character disorders no psychiatric
abnormalities were present in these
subjects the doctor wrote in a journal
article about the prison's LSD
experiments finally to make it all seem
legal and ethical white he sat down on
August 6th 1957 with one of dr.
Pfeiffer's associates and signed on the
dotted line it was a document of
disclosure explaining the benefits and
risks that dr. Pfeiffer had created
specifically for this LSD project and
the one-page for
barring the sync signature of James J
Bulger carried a heading in capital
letters contract between Department of
Pharmacology Emory University School of
Medicine and human volunteers at US
Penitentiary Atlanta Georgia so that's
the kind of thing we were able to get
our hands on ourselves was Whitey's
so-called contract to participate in the
LSD project to continue one morning two
months later after eating a light
breakfast in the dining hall wide he was
taken by a guard to the hospital a
building located on the west side of the
prison compound behind the B cell house
where he had been kept initially in the
eight-man cell with a prison population
of more than 2600 the size of many small
towns across America the hospital was
fully operational it had 75 beds and for
full time doctors assisted by eleven
medical technicians prisoners staffed
other positions from clerk to head
operating nurse in any given year 250
major and 750 minor surgical procedures
were performed why do you walk through
the main door the main floor and down
into the basement to ward F or the
neuropsychiatric ward where a large room
secured with a steel door and steel bars
was set aside for the LSD project-wide
he was a member of the Tuesday group of
eight inmate volunteers checking in for
a 24 hours day he walked into the plain
sterile room with its eight beds and
joined the others by now wide he knew
the drill he'd been part of the LSD
project for more than a month he sat on
the bed the doctors always in Kurds
subjects to remain in bed for the
duration by 8:30 a.m. for about two
hours after breakfast wide he took the
LSD dosage prepared for him drinking it
in a glass of quinine flavored liquid
the drug was odorless and colorless then
he waited would this be what the doctors
called a trivial dose meaning 25
micrograms or something stronger
in his first month he'd been given
increasingly stronger doses of the
psychedelic drug so that he could as one
doctor wrote become fully familiar with
the effects of the drug both
qualitatively and quantitatively the
first dosage was 25 micrograms the
second 50 and 75 and finally 100 whitey
would know in about an hour the strength
of the dose after the symptoms began to
manifest when the LSD began working on
his brain and causing havoc in the
interaction between his nerve cells and
the neurotransmitter serotonin in the
human body this the serotonin system
that acts as a kind of control tower for
behavior perceptions and moods the first
sign whitey was on his way was a
sensation that the lights were
alternately dimming and brightening as
if someone were playing with the power
supply in fact the lights were constant
but his pupils were dilating changing in
diameter and affecting his light
perception to help him pin down the
power of this trip dr. Pfeiffer or an
associate would soon come by to ask a
series of 28 questions certain questions
address symptoms evident from taking a
low dose does the light bother you do
you feel fatigued others addressed
symptoms seen only with higher dosage
dosages are things moving around you do
you feel as if in a dream
why do you would know the dose was on
the stronger side if when he closed his
eyes he saw an array of geometric
patterns accompanied by a kaleidoscope
of colors I don't know who when the
rooms been there but that's what it's
like letting go could not have come
easily
whitey bulger had always felt most
secure when in control but prison had
changed all that he'd lost nearly every
measure of control the eight-man cell
being one ever-present reminder
hallucinating on LSD meant losing even
more for someone who has a tremendous
need for security through control this
could lead to a tremendous sense of
anxiety dr. John Halpern a psychiatrist
at McLean Hospital Massachusetts
commented later about the combustible
mix of Whitey Bulger in LSD
it was October 8 1957 when whitey began
this particular round of the drug the
date was exactly one week after America
bees began sending b-52 bombers loaded
with nuclear weapons airborne
around-the-clock in case of a Soviet
attack and it was only four days after
the Soviet Union shocked America with
its successful launch of the Sputnik
satellite the focus of the world was on
the Cold War and Russia's ride into
space while whitey was lying in a bed in
Ward F bracing himself for a different
kind of trip featuring tangerine trees
and marmalade skies okay so hopefully
that gives you a flavor of what the kind
of storytelling that all this new
material enabled us whether it was his
actual prison file whether it was the
prison inmate publication the Atlantean
secret CIA files that have since become
public and working all this material and
having documents about whitey and each a
calendar of the days and times when he
participated as a member of the Tuesday
group week in and week out going down
there to you know to drop acid so with
that I'd like to turn it over briefly to
Jerry who will talk a little bit as I
said about our history with the story
and then we'd like to open it up to the
floor to questions because in the past
we found that people have plenty to say
and ask about when it comes to this
story okay thanks thank you thank you I
sought to have the historical context
for it I think what dick and I bring to
this this discussion is a unique
historical perspective we came to this
story early and we've stayed late it's a
career undertaking and it has a body of
work that goes with it the chronology is
it stats 25 years ago when as
investigative reporters for the globe we
did a series of articles
on the tube Bulger brothers at the
height of their power and at that time
we revealed what he was an FBI informant
the reverberations from that were strong
and lasting and there recounted in the
book that we're talking about tonight
way the next stop was ten years after
the revelation about the informant we
did black mass which dick talked about
which Chronicle quantico's the FBI
descent into total corruption the Boston
office and we were able to hint at some
of the depravity of Whitey Bulger that's
going to be come a movie
hopefully production starts in May I
mean that's Hollywood scheduling but a
lot of fits and starts about the movie
in Black Mass but I think we have some
reason reason for optimism now at least
we got a good director and Barry
Levinson quite accomplished and finally
here we are tonight soup to nuts on
whitey third installment on this long
story
Dick's auto recap pretty much everything
but I would like to stress that it's
comprehensive and a full blown biography
and it goes back two centuries we trace
them back to their roots and
Newfoundland and I had done some
research on the emigration to Boston
from the famine in the mid nineteenth
century and I was surprised and
fascinated to learn that the most
durable and lasting emigration from
Island was from Waterford Harbor and
southern island to st. John's
Newfoundland so we had we had a lot of
new information to bring to bear on that
dick and I had been investigative
reporters our whole career we asked a
lot of people a lot of tough questions
so it's now which you are trying to turn
the tables and and fire away you know
one of questions about the the writing
the Rees
in the history of it in your in your
research did you did you find it
remarkable that congressman Joe Moakley
long term congressman Joe Moakley who
lived through all this and came away
with a clean slate and what he must have
known what was going on if you in fact
was not an enabler
I mean they've named bridges after him
is it were you surprised at how clean he
key he's a good friend of cobalt or it
was noble to cave in zoology as far as I
know he staked
he stayed clean I never I never saw
anything that would implicate him in
anything yeah I mean that is a good and
interesting question I mean we didn't in
terms of this prison file that had you
know drying ins fingerprints on it and
John McCormick's Mowgli's we're not
there remarkable yeah thank you
sounds like there's quite an education
anybody could have with this book I'm
really looking forward to it
I haven't read the other either and I
was um stopped brought up a little short
with the anyone you said how masterfully
whitey had used the FBI and I guess I've
heard a lot about how masterfully the
FBI was able to exploit and use Whitey
Bulger and I wondered if you could just
say something about that side of the
relationship well that's news to me
but the FBI exploited my mojo I don't I
mean he he gave them some information
but he certainly was the taker on that
proposition yeah it was an imbalance of
power in the end and I think instead of
the FBI
taking advantage of whitey or getting
some huge benefit I think if we zoomed
in closer to certain FBI agents within
the FBI world namely John Connolly who
was white he's officially white he's
handler and is also at the center of the
storm center of the corruption having
Whitey Bulger getting him to sign on as
an informant it was a career-maker for
John Connolly who was also from South
Boston and his supervisor was a man by
the name of John Morris again also very
much in the center of corruption at the
heart of this for them riding whitey and
his and Whitey's partner Steve Fleming
who was also an informant starting from
the mid-70s on until the late 80s again
where they were career makers so in that
sense and and they they exploited it
professionally they kept them on even
when they should have cut them loose and
going after them so individually
personally professionally I think it
benefited a handful of people but
institutionally it's it's turned out to
be the worst informant scandal in the
history of the FBI and even for the
individuals it was their undoing brought
them all down when they Conley still in
prison John Morrison total disgrace so
even though they
the way for a while they crashed at the
end two questions of Korea's all the
investigative reporters and research any
fierce feel life and death threats not
with him around now they tell you the
only the most intimidating thing we
encountered I think that speak for
myself with the FBI try to talk us out
of the original story in 1988 about
revealing bellicose an informant and
they said that he would have no
compunctions about killing us all so
that that gets you full attention
sure I mean Kevin weeks threatened on
Howie Carr I think publicly and so I
just wanted to make folks ran into that
yeah it's also hard to go back in time
now to 1988 when in that period the idea
of publishing or I mean discovering and
then publishing that whitey had this
special relationship this informant
thing with the FBI I mean it was
jaw-dropping and unthinkable I mean
whitey was reputation was not only as
the ultimate stand-up gangster who
demanded and required supreme loyalty
that was his reputation but he also had
this reputation as being the Robin Hood
of the underworld something you know
charismatic about him and all that kind
of thing so you know we were I mean it
took us a long time to even wrap our
heads around it when we were getting
close to confirming it and now I mean
it's all it's a given it's accepted we
might live with it my big concern and
and I joke with the editor of the globe
was that we could set off a gang war and
if the bodies dumped on fun steps of the
globe I don't think the publisher will
like that much and it was it was a
daunting undertaking
who really was a hottest call I have
enemy
well I commend your bravery the other
question trooper Billy Johnson had
whitey in custody at Logan Airport and
an order came down from some place to
release him in your research or in your
opinions where did that oughta come from
well that that's always been a confusing
thing to me because the allegation was
that Dave Davis who was head of the Port
Authority intervened and between
Alliance and was supposedly Bill Bulger
reaching the head of the Port Authority
to to interfere in that case but as far
as we could tell that was never
documented and I think unfortunately the
the trooper may have exaggerated in his
own mind the the problems that ensued
after his encounter with Whitey Bulger
thank you thank you
one of the you mentioned that baltra was
the only one that pulled this nuttin
with the FBI in New York there was a guy
named de Vecchio Lyn Lindsay I think are
literally the de Vecchio and he was
working with the Colombo family and
there were about thirty two murders
there he was report you know working
with one faction they were they were
fighting in there and he was acquitted
at trial in a state court and what they
what they did it seemed like the day
when they pulled that stunt with with
Sawadee and the mone they were using the
state courts to do their bidding because
there was less questioning of the
federal agents seems to how they
manipulate the state courts what I want
to ask you about is are we to believe
that after James Bulger went became a
fugitive that all of these gambling
rings and drug dealers they just
evaporated and all the police that were
providing protection and the FBI agents
we're providing protection just went
straight and all of this all the
criminal activity just stopped in the in
Massachusetts I mean you know there's
nothing else I read your first book and
I've read almost all the other books
written about this stuff and it's like
nothing else is going on anymore since
he became a fugitive make sense well
it's hardly the case on the street there
are but no one has risen to the level of
notoriety or power to replace a Whitey
Bulger to play a replace in the Mafia
Jerry and jewel oh this mafia remnants
and then North End the cheese man was
rather bumbling and it's in jail and
that certainly there's his people have
taken Whitey's place in South Boston but
never present to that I mean why do you
operate was a cult of personality I mean
he he didn't create an organization like
them off in a sense that there were
lines of succession or whatnot when he's
gone a thing basically did collapse and
it's been reorganized in smaller ways
and in smaller groups and I can't even
begin to tell you who
because we don't cover it anymore but I
know from talking to law enforcement
that there's still plenty of you know
bookmaking in long loan-sharking and
drug dealing and all the kinds of things
that whitey had amassed an a normal
enormous amount of centralized authority
and power over my mind the question is
about the investigation by John Durham
when he found you know John Connolly was
a you know a problem and also a poor
Rico but beyond that there was nobody
else in the Boston office of the FBI
that knew about this or was
participating I mean what about the
people that that pulled the frame-up of
the four you know cell body and Limone
and Greco and Tamil oh what about those
FBI yeah no you I mean you're making a
good point and what you're speaking to
is that in all the court hearings and
and all the investigations looking into
you know going past John Connolly and
his supervisor John Morris trying to to
you know track the the institutional
corruption at the FBI to get you get the
public's arms around it so we know how
deep and it ran and all that and we've
never had a full accounting that's true
we've had a fuller accounting that maybe
you realized I mean in our book we
certainly named other agents who never
were prosecuted but certainly their
names have been brought in and certainly
white whitey and his associates had them
on their pad according to their internal
documents that get the Christmas
envelopes and whatnot they may never
have been prosecuted so it's harder to
to see all that but it's it's in it's in
our book and and that is disappointing
about this prosecutor you mentioned
Durham from Connecticut who came up and
prosecuted John Connolly we were all
waiting for a report that documented and
explained in full fuller detail that was
promised to never took place and the
information book whitey names seven
agents who took gifts or money from
Whitey Bulger and it comes from a law
enforcement and briefings of you know
whitey Bulger's associates and then we
hear that you know the statute of
limitations that we had Ron on some of
those crimes and so they they end up
not being prosecuted that's one of the
things in a way that I look forward to
you know with Whitey's trial scheduled
for June and Whitey's defense attorney
Jay Carney is clearly you know he's one
of the best around and and he's doing
everything he can to make it ugly for
the government and I'm okay with that in
a way because I'm hopeful that we're
gonna find out some more about the FBI
and the institutional corruption that's
a piece that I wanted to know more about
because that's the thing ultimately that
matters or shouldn't matter to to most
of us I mean there are the cops we
expect the bad guys to be bad but what
about the cops
you know that's my more question I mean
if it nobody is alright I got plenty of
questions one of the things that go in
one of the things that they do in New
York City especially and sometimes in
New York State is they form a commission
to investigate the police and/or the
state police because by their nature
they have so much power over us that
they become corrupt it's just the nature
of them and they do a lot of bad things
and there's never as far as I know in in
recent history been any investigation of
the police departments in Massachusetts
or the FBI and and in fact as far as I
know there's never been an investigation
the FBI nationally which is another big
problem so you know they get into a
place where they're doing so many bad
things and they get away with it becomes
normal and it's criminal but they're
doing it it's normal
so what island says why isn't there any
pushier wasn't it some these blue-ribbon
Commission's in Massachusetts to
investigate the police here as they
doing they are you know like the Knapp
Commission or melon melon melon question
that the scale in New York is so much
different twenty-two thousand police
officers mm mm but you raise a very good
question I I'm convinced from 30 years
of investigative stuff that if you work
vice in Boston if you and if you work
drugs in Boston
you have you have to be on to take I
mean that's that's sweeping and probably
too sweeping I'm sure there are
exceptions but
you know if you don't take in those
squads you're frozen out your roster
size so it's it's it's the way it works
it's also I mean it's you know that's a
question for the governor I guess or
someone else in the way I'm serious I
mean journalism can play its role and
what what its role is to you know the in
theory ideally to be the watchdog and to
reveal things but we don't have subpoena
power we can't call commissions we can
and and and it's an important role that
the globe plays and continues to play is
to uncover these things and then it's a
handoff some other part of our
democratic process supposed to pick it
up I think one of the one of the hardest
investigative things that we did was to
find that there were two drug detectives
in Boston who their drug related to a
really robberies because what's a drug
dealer to do when all the money and all
that drugs are on the table and the
police come in and they scoop it up how
could who is he gonna report the theft
of his his illegal drug money too so we
were able to document that was a very
hard deal not and the Boston Police
fought us very hard on that but those
two cops went to jail I agree with you
that there is a problem and that's my
question so how where can here we can
get this done considering you need a
group of citizens can go to court you
know at five or 10 you know be stopped
three-quarters found found a place where
were that so kind of a flip side of that
same coin the FBI thought they were the
good guys because initially of course it
was their intent was to break up the
Italian mafia oh I'm sorry sorry the
whole time the Whitey Bulger was on the
run you know we all I think mostly in
the Boston area kind of knew that if the
FBI or the federal government wanted to
find him they would have found him
and that there was a reason why they
weren't finding him now if you think
back and I think it might have been in
your book black mass governor he wasn't
governor at the time
Mel weld was the federal prosecutor that
was overseeing that entire project if
you will and that there was a state cop
that actually made his way into his
office to talk to him because at the
time the state police in the state of
Massachusetts they were the only clean
cops
really they were the watchdog's and and
bill weld shot him out then he became
governor and it was kind of interesting
I actually worked with the legislative
service bureau at the State House during
the time that Billy Bulger was was there
and every time you would do an interview
his back was always against the wall you
know ironically enough my questioning is
thank you do you remember when they
actually a federal committee was formed
and they brought Billy Bulger in and he
took the fifth on every question do you
remember that yeah there was a grand
jury investigation that had been
convened in part to find out who if
anyone is helping why'd he stay out
there and initially he took the fifth
okay but then he did testify he had to
testify before Congress because taking
the fifth in front of a grand jury was
deemed a civic-minded for president of
university of massachusetts so anyway it
bubbled up to Congress and he he he
claims he he had one conversation with
whitey and then that was it that that's
that's dubious but it is all we can
document really yeah yeah it's amazing
the two brothers that grew up in South
Boston during that time and there's no
evidence but the two of them never had a
conversation she said there was one that
was documented now there are plenty of
and we write extensively about it
plenty of conversations documented
between whitey and the other brother
Jackie Bulger so I mean they didn't need
to talk to Bill Bulger they got Jackie
talking well the old estate Billy Billy
ran it from from the Statehouse and
whitey ran it on the streets and very
effectively as a matter of fact and if
you pissed off Billy you were shut out
and you basically had no income and if
you please Tim then you put you in a
nice cushy job at the MBTA or whatever
but the point being is that it's gonna
be interesting yes with the prosecution
because can you imagine the nuggets that
are gonna fall out of that I mean bill
weld it wasn't realized and Kovarian
George kaberi nobody talks about him
okay that poor man was we got to get to
some questions I think the point being
is that I guess my question is will
Billy ever be prosecuted or do you think
they will ever not in having nothing to
do with his brother whitey on his own
well there is there is a chapter in
writing on Bill's testimony before
Congress being highly questionable
it was reprisal legislation that
targeted a state state police commander
who was after whitey and would have
forced him to retire or take a reduction
in pay
how Bill's position has always been they
had nothing to do with that he doesn't
know where where I came from and it was
none of his going that on the other hand
Stevie Fleming's and histor briefing
with law enforcement said what he went
to bill and asked him to put this in as
a budget amendment so that's that's in
the book I mean you can draw your own
conclusion who you want to believe I
mean I'm sure Bill's argument would be C
Flemmi so you know a murderer
and how can you trust him but he was
debriefed on the basis that if he told a
lie he'd face a capital capital
punishment trial in Oklahoma or Florida
so there's that
can I check I'm sorry no can we get to
another question a salut thank you
I didn't have a microphone
at the risk of mentioning your
competition in the publishing world was
that somebody else from the globe just a
couple of people from the globe recently
published something about whitey yeah
what's going on with this song and dance
that what he's doing with mr. Sunday and
the letters you talked early on about
why he wanting to be in control and I
have a feeling that he is seems anyone
know what she's referring to
no nobody's ever heard of that yeah okay
well there's the globe has been running
stories and in connection with their
book about whitey but one of the things
have been running about is they've have
a relationship with a former inmate by
the name of Richard Sunday who was
Whitey's pal and Alcatraz we also
interviewed him and he's in our book as
well
but why he writes him letters and
Richard gives those letters to the globe
and it's like open mic wide he gets to
talk at nauseam and and there was
another version of it today in the story
so and he gets to talk about what what I
call what a good bad guy I am
that's his theme so in Richard Sunday's
an old pal and he lets the word out and
and there's no question in my mind that
the letters have value and there's news
in there but like I say there's also a
time to step in and take the mic away a
little bit and add maybe some
perspective
yes ma'am
the dichotomy between bill and whitey is
it's very strong though the line of
demarcation is very strong bill is a
very accomplished man on the right side
of the law I think I read that he knows
Greek and he knows Latin and he's very
accomplished and has a very layered
career in politics and outside of
politics and then you have whitey do you
have a way to account for how these two
guys in this house did this in their
house one went this way and one went the
other and do you also have a read on how
bill might feel about the brother from
from the wrong side of the tracks
yeah that's layered in the book
throughout in terms of their their
incredibly close relationship
unbelievable I mean that was astonishing
to realize how far back and how deep and
help we're able to document that back to
the housing projects when they're boys
and you know Bill being the younger of
the two I think it's a lot more
complicated than then then you begin
describing that there's good bill and
there's bad whitey one's account there
they're both accomplished in their
fields and I think they share a lot of
the same traits to get caught do you
think it was time for him to turn
himself in I know when in the papers
that came from Sweden or another state
but it's hard for me to believe that he
lived in California in that unit but all
the Abbott Iseman that was going on was
it was a time that he turned himself in
basically on this I don't think so so
someone did get a million-dollar reward
that happen definitely happen I know
there was you know there's a lot of
skepticism being voiced in here about
how things seem to have gone down and
and especially after his capture you
know the FBI was standing up for the big
high-five I mean they
arrested their man and no one believed
him and still I mean we're hearing it
tonight we were and we were not able to
find out anything that would contradict
the way it happened and nor has anyone
else it happened the way it happened
it really is but I think of what it
reflects is that when it went when it
comes to Whitey Bulger
the FBI has absolutely no credibility
okay and so instead of a parade they
were still taking it in the chin and and
to this day they are and that I think
just reflects the depth and the and and
how long and how deeply embedded you
know they're they're tarnished
reputation is when it comes to Whitey
Bulger because it's we're not talking
that's again it what makes it so a store
we're not talking about a single murder
case or a think a single investigation
that was compromised because agents made
wrong choices on the fly or something
and they were compromised we're talking
about a way of life a culture that went
on and some you know we all some of us
have all lived through it and stuff like
that and that's what's sometimes hard to
you know fully appreciate a grasp is
that it was a way of life an FBI culture
and sure that I think in you know
there's a question referring to New York
and there were other incidents of
corruption but nothing like Boston
nothing like what went down here and I
think you know we're gonna be paying a
price you know for years to come I think
for the FBI you you reap what you sow
and they're disgraceful performance for
for at least two-thirds of Whitey's life
on the lam I think they're stuck with
that tough luck is there one more
question I think we have time for one
more
no yeah go ahead shout it out like
shocked that they did so it just it does
seem like they really weren't looking
for him well that's true I mean you know
that's you're asking the questions we
were asking you know and other and then
you know other people have been asking
ever since he was captured and it looks
like maybe you know in the beginning
there might have been you know when he
first went away because there's still
too many people who are directly
involved in the corruption and you know
they really weren't out looking for him
kind of thing but in more recent years
you know
you know we've talked to a lot of people
they weren't really looking for them
because they do you know what more to do
it's not like they didn't want to find
him I know a lot of FBI and I know a lot
in law enforcement they wanted nothing
better I mean the page of history had
turned we're talking about a whole new
generation of agents and what a feather
in their cap to capture this guy so but
but you know they had this task force
and they always talked the big talk
about how every agent everywhere is
looking for this guy but then you get
behind it and no that's not the case
they just you know remember 9/11
happened and you know that's a bigger
problem I think than finding whitey so
the allocation of resources so there
were stretches when and and some of the
guys looking form they genuine genuine
believed and concluded he was dead they
couldn't confirm it but that was their
hunch so sometimes there's just a few
guys you know the lot you know that with
the lights on in the office going what
do we do today but it kind of got rammed
up there at the end with it with the
entry of the u.s. marshals
and I think they made a difference in
that last year one last question I think
yes ma'am
I recognize you you've been to events
before well we ventured we've been to
course a lot from his arraignment with
his Moll Catherine Greig right up to
with Mary Ann bowler listening to JW
Carney whine constantly and then and
then pushing his buttons to change the
date and whatever so my question is do
you think judge Stern because that that
hasn't come down yet do you think judge
Stern is going to be the presiding judge
over the Whitey Bulger trial I do you do
I don't
we're not the appeals court though no
it's taken a long time January 7 yeah I
think they could have said no when they
didn't so who knows because he we went
last weekend and judge Stern presided
he's gonna yeah I do I think he's like I
think he's come out you know there's
been a we're talking about there's been
a real challenge a legal challenge to
the presiding judge because when in the
80s he was head of the Criminal Division
of the US Attorney's Office
so Carney has been arguing that and as
the the standard is an appearance of a
conflict that and Carney says he wants
to call him as a witness and join and
all this kind of stuff so if it's an
appearance of a problem I think he's you
know
carnies kind of I think it's us
persuaded me I think it's a psycho yeah
I could blow it yeah it's definitely the
habit well say yeah that's that's a big
pending issue right right right yeah
okay well thanks so much for turning out
thank you
[Applause]